to this game the bar is over jerry
canson's side
yeah and uh that is because white is one
porn up in the position computers they
do still love their material these days
uh computers they value sacrifices they
understand strategic things a bit more
but white being a pawn up is the reason
why the evaluation bar is in eric's
favor that being said black has great
practical compensation i'm especially
looking at the light squares white has
no light squared bishop that's been
traded off so black's light square
bishop on this long diagonal might cause
some real trouble also black's queen
just edging her way closer to the white
king
some real uh pitfalls for eric to avoid
along the way if he wants to consolidate
his extra pawn simon i have no doubts
you'd rather be on the black side here
yeah i mean i always like having the
initiative and you find at these time
limits as well it's much more important
generally to have the initiative
you know i'd love to see eric get
through and as i'm sure all of his fans
would as well
the good news is he does have that pawn
he does have an unbalanced position and
uh he realizes going into this opening
that he's given the initiative away but
so what you know he's got to win he's
got to just try to weather the storm
here
i like his last move his last move
has i guess an intention of pushing the
other pawn in the center and trying to
block out that very strong bishop that
you mentioned and uh this is uh this is
a very clever strategy generally using
your pawns to block your opponent's
bishops and if he's able to get that
move on the board then
i expect black's compensation won't be
enough but tempo very important timing
very important in chess especially when
you've gambited a pawn so black now
moving his bishop in keeping the frets
uh on the board eric moving immediately
developing his knight but all to play
for here uh every everything pretty much
on the board is an extra pawn just got
to take it to the ending eric and take
it to the playoff yeah and uh really
surprised he played this movie so
quickly because some calculation is
required um on eric's part because after
this knights jumped forward we could see
knight takes knight for example a trade
and black's bishop jumping forward and
capturing this knight hoping the white
recaptures and suddenly look at the
white king really weak and these pawns
really ugly but i guess the idea is to
ignore this bishop and capture the other
bishop instead
that being said white's king now under
some real pressure on the light squares
the bishop could step back
i'm struggling to understand why he
played it so quickly there's so much to
calculate the white queen will be hit
and if she moves to a bad square maybe
there are better squares but then
suddenly that's there are some serious
threats against the white king ivanka
you didn't you didn't look at it i did i
didn't like the look that move at all i
mean the only thing that i can think of
is you know maybe he's calculated that
the queens can potentially come off and
then
this uh light square domination that
black has
might not be so bad so in this position
bring the queen to this yeah just to
offer a trade of queens and you know and
if black threatens checkmate on this
square then you can still persist with
the idea of trading queens still this
isn't really a winning attempt and eric
needs to win so opposite kind of bishops
again which we've had again
so many times today it seems to be a
theme here's the thing today yeah
isolated pawn opposite bishops and that
other rook thing that goes around the
board um so yeah i mean
it's funny here i mean knight takes
night is critical um estopianco will be
thinking about this again so what is
what is the idea um
i mean it's all pretty forcing after
that move right if black captures the
white knight and then as we saw black
bishop jumping and taking a white knight
everything's forced there
i don't i don't see it myself either um
can you just go so if you go pawn takes
knight takes night you just recapture
the pawn
and if you take my knight i recapture
whoa
i'm scared that line we showed with the
white king being very open weak pawns
around it i think then black's rook
would swing across and uh start
threatening some stuff it just looks
really dangerous for eric right now
and uh maybe if he's accurate he can
defend that one but
good news espnko time is uh half nearly
half of eric's time so he's keeping that
pressure on this is where you get
nervous
you see these ideas and you double check
you start doubting yourself as well so
um you know it's but i i don't know what
the i don't know what solution is here
after after capturing it and capturing
both pieces opening up the white king
especially when again you only need that
draw we saw magnus had in the last game
is following that theme where you have
many opportunities okay you might not
check mate but you get perpetual check
that's all you need to go through
and that often happens these complex
positions
you know the the one thing that might
prevent uh andreas penco
from going for that type of variation is
the fact that he doesn't really like to
defend when he's a pawn down or go for
end games where he's slightly worse so
if for example that line we showed the
queen's come off yes it's opposite
colour bishops but he is a pawn down
black would be on the defending side and
it's not really his style essepenko
prefers to be
in the slightly better side of those
types of positions putting the pressure
on and just kind of slowly
edging forward with a small advantage
so maybe he's looking for something else
i don't really see what else black
should try right now
it just looks so direct just going for
that line knight takes night
trading lots of things off and trying to
go for the white king as you mentioned
earlier assignment if white gets time to
push the white d-pawn forward to d5
blocking in black's pride and joy the
light squared bishop
then i think white is in charge so
timing is everything and unless there's
a clear alternative esse pen code has to
just speed up play that move play the
quick flurry of uh play that whole
variation and six minutes now though so
yeah so maybe maybe we can have a look
at it again because that that that does
because are we missing something yeah i
mean it just
it like it takes night yeah just run
through this night takes night you have
to recapture right
yeah unless you yeah i don't see
anything else yeah okay now bishop takes
night very good we're doing well and
then i think you have to take you have
to take the dark square bishop yeah and
now you know black even has his choice
of just actually stepping up the rook
bringing it across you're bringing it
across you know three's magic number we
haven't seen that today that idea
um it yeah maybe i could get greedy here
ivanka and take this bishop and just if
you'd give me a check i'm going to run
away this way yeah to safety
it looks scary does it look scary you
have to have so much confidence in your
uh you know calculating abilities to
play lines like this and just the speed
that eric played this we know how good
he is at calculating he's gone backwards
wow
very surprising that is really
surprising it might be a good move but
uh you know it doesn't look right to go
backwards in such a position just to
explain the idea behind this strange
looking knight retreat black has opened
up his bishop he's threatening now a big
threat bishop takes knight shattering
the white pawn structure
white cannot allow that but the problem
is also this knight is helping the
attack of this pawn so black now wants
to play pawn takes pawn and after a
recapture use his knight so for example
if white does indeed play them if he
wants and blocks this bishop in we will
see a trade on this square and black's
knight will jump forward and suddenly
black's doing great again
uh
this pawn very weak suddenly this knight
threatening to take the white bishop and
black is doing okay
so yeah maybe it's even cleverer than
what we thought putting pressure on this
pawn as mentioned but also opening up a
direct threat
how does white deal with both of these
it's not actually that easy yeah i mean
i'd always like to play the most active
move and uh there's there's a threat to
my pawn so can i move my knight which is
under attack into the center of the
board and uh the other idea of this
is uh well i get out of the way to
bishop i defend my pawn uh but your your
queen is kind of lacking some squares
over on the king side and i just really
want to get the queen's off as white
right like queen comes in front of the
rook and i just really want to bring my
queen
over to defend my king if i can get
those queens off i'm a pawn up in the
ending got great winning chances so this
kind of this kind of idea looks looks uh
playable i mean f is still so complex
here you can kick that knight away
always a good idea someone moves a piece
into your half of the board you're like
no get out of get out of my house and
give it a little kick with the pawn so
um
again
what what's happening here after the
pawn moves up yeah
complex this knight could drop back
hitting the black bishop and
i mean this is going to get crazy but we
could see a trade here for example and
it all depends on whether black can try
and break through towards the white king
using this diagonal if you give white
one more move and shutting down this
bishop with a pawn push then white is
winning if not maybe black is doing
quite well so it's really complicated
and very every move matters yeah it's a
very brave play from eric here yeah
because he's got a he's got to win but
he's playing
given his opponent the initiative and
normally that that is that's even
scarier i mean i i i hate defending uh i
don't know about you you guys i mean
this is one thing i just can't do i
can't defend in chess i mean ivanka you
you love grabbing pawns yeah so you you
you have to defend sometimes i guess
right but i mean i just can't do it i
always freak out and just like stop
start worrying when i get attacked i
hate being attacked do you
don't like it giving all my secrets away
now as well
yeah just i i always find it
uncomfortable if my king is exposed yeah
if it's out there a bit nude or
something you've got no clothes on then
i'm like oh bit bit concerned i'm not
very good at handling that and lately
i've been getting my king trapped in
mating nets
that's not what you want to do it's not
what i want to do you know i've been
winning and then suddenly oh god
goodness me
my king is getting mated so actually i
would say no no david what about you i
mean i'd like you i'm trying to find any
weaknesses in your game it's hard but i
i mean you you normally calculate your
way out of trouble it seems quite often
you you rely uh on your calculation
maybe like eric is doing here
it might i've had many positions against
you where i've it looks like i have a
scary position but i just haven't
calculated as well as you so uh but yeah
bit of a personal choice i guess yeah i
would say sometimes i rely a bit too
much on calculation that's uh maybe my
issue and also these days i don't
really trust myself when attacking as
much as i used to so if i get a position
where i have to attack
um then sometimes i don't commit as
quickly as i should
um so those i would say are my
weaknesses defending i've enjoyed more
and more as i get older i like having i
like being really grabbing a strategic
kind of advantage or grabbing a pawn or
something and just clinging on and
hoping that it gives me a long-term win
but uh yeah i mean i wish i was
still the attacking force that i used to
be or that you are now still simon's not
sure about that everyone i think has
problems with their own game that they
want to improve right and uh talking
about uh someone who is probably going
to come up with some attacking potential
i really have to show you this selfie
that hazel has
and uh hazel shows us a future grand
master and it's look at it it's a
newborn baby
that's got the potential to be a
grandmaster yeah so gotta start early
exactly yeah it's a little bit too early
isn't it yeah
different pieces you know exactly get to
get a chest to be there like first
language yeah yeah yeah
i did i did actually share a room with
an english international master uh it
was in galsdal when you were playing as
well and uh he he he really loved his
chess but what he would do at night time
okay so he'd be sharing a room he'd put
on his headphones
and he'd listen to dvds while he slept
chess dvds and he said well i
subconsciously um absorbing all the
information where i sleep so he'd be
looking at chess all day and he'd go to
bed and he'd put on like you know
a dvd or chess to sleep to because he
thought subconsciously he'd be
memorizing those moves
why did it work yeah i was gonna ask
dude i was very tempted to move rooms
because i was wondering if he's gonna do
that what else is he capable of doing um
um so it's not coincidence simon that
you ended up producing many dvds and
courses yourself i might subconsciously
for yeah this is something like this is
yeah it's very strange but i don't know
the subconscious way of learning i i
don't know if it's a thing or not but
strange can you guess the player i think
i know okay we won't say anything
you have to no i'll tell you after the
show
yeah he's a lovely chap i think it was
galstal
2005 for anyone who wants to go and
research
okay so meanwhile we saw white's knight
not take the most active route uh into
the center that simon was advocating
that we actually showed on the board a
few minutes ago white's knight stepped
back and now black's knight
saw the queue to jump forward and white
has finally locked down that really
strong black light squared bishop so
both sides have reason to be happy
black's knight now doing a good job can
actually eliminate white's remaining
bishop trade off there that would be
tempting to me black's knight can
continue to dance towards the white king
but at least white has shut down one
black piece so if sf penco doesn't play
energetically doesn't play accurately
over the next few turns white's extra
pawn will become a big big factor
what do you think can you see anything
direct here for black uh guys because he
needs something direct before it's too
late especially with the clock situation
down to four minutes that's a pencil
yeah i mean i suppose the most natural
idea would be to take that bishop off
you get the two bishops you've got a
dark square bishop which is incredibly
powerful and you can start using that
but
i don't know if it's enough because
white's pawns in the center are
fantastic and i i i really like the way
white's playing this eric is going about
this because
he's he's he's calculating it seems very
well and uh so far so good for him so
far definitely so good time advantage as
well
um esopian not trying to break free here
with this with this pawn push he wants
to break free
and it's all about this piece right yep
so not going for this trade yet that i
just showed which has some pros has some
cons
instead keeping that one on the back
burner for later instead trying to
undermine white's strong point and this
is uh quite thematic normally if your
opponent has a pawn chain you want to
eliminate the head of the pawn chain and
whoa what a move by eric are you so
shocked everyone you don't move pawns in
front you're king hey
it doesn't win a piece as well what is
the idea it's a fork maybe he thought he
was winning here but after knight takes
bishop he doesn't win the black queen
because his own queen is under fire but
he has to win this game is he taking
chances basically big risks big risks by
eric hanson and look at the evaluation
bar hates it because yes white's a porn
up but this king
is just so open and it will be for the
rest of the game black's queen under
fire has stepped back and if the bishops
break through towards the white king
it's going to be game over it's so scary
now as white no matter what the computer
evaluation says even if it says white is
fine
in practical terms this is i can never
play a move like that even if it was a
good move i mean he's he eric knows he
has to win and he's playing these
extremely risky moves uh
maybe this poor mover essa pienko just
this little pawn break that he played
was just a fantastic move uh and the
more i'm looking at that move it seems
like oh actually okay the bishop is
coming alive and eric thought he was
forced to to do this i mean it's still
game on though still game on the knight
comes to the center knight in the center
is a very powerful piece bar is
definitely alive yeah we're going to
find out an answer to bishops against
knights which are better
as a team because it is two bishops
against two knights and
still looking at that white king yeah
pawns don't move backwards and there's
so many weaknesses he would love to
cover with a pawn retreat right now but
uh yeah that's not gonna happen but i i
have to say the more i look at eric's
move more i'm like how is black going to
break through and open those diagonals
those two knights are doing a sterling
job it's just not possible is it and the
time look at the time he's keeping the
pressure on yeah and espn kai is visibly
i think uh getting a little bit more you
know nervous as well so
yeah okay he's got to prove it here you
know um from panko's point of view your
opponents just played a really ugly
surprising move
it feel i think it's human nature you
just want to punish them right so he's
going to burn a lot of time trying to
punish eric now for playing this really
reckless move okay he doesn't have that
time can you try to break things down by
just playing bishop takes knight i don't
really want to play this but it's a
forcing move we should uh generally look
at the most forcing moves first those
knights are blocking everything let's
get rid of one of those nights yes i
lose my bishop pair but i need to break
down this blockade in the middle of the
board and uh
if i can win pawn back okay that's
that's something i do but yeah maybe
maybe that's what he's trying to
calculate now that's a good question
because if the knight steps back rook
takes rook and then you win a pawn in
the process or maybe even this pawn if
you wanted it and if uh okay we have
seen this move and if queen takes then
now the night long no longer protects
this guy so i'm expecting politics porn
this is the idea right simon yeah and
the bishop will regain the pawn and it's
on a great diagonal as well to try and
expose the white king later
suddenly eric has he lost control or i
mean according to the evaluation but
he's doing great this is surprising it
looks so scary
wow yeah
i'm trying to figure it out you know i'm
like my mind is going and overload here
so it's like okay
queen is there some night jumps to
attack the light squared bishop could
there be something smart like that yeah
i think after pawn takes pawn there's
there must be uh some some night move
here right yeah so this is this is
maybe why the evaluation bar likes likes
eric's uh idea um
yeah
brave chess but needed to be brave yeah
fortune does favor the brave after all
as we learn many times in chess so
um okay let's go back to the players
because this one will heat up we're
expecting to see queen takes bishop
right now moving that black bishop on
board and uh yep still very tense
still eric hansen with extra time but
currently an extra pawn the favorite but
it could all change in the course of one
move especially is going to be using
hanson's time now to try and whip up
some attack against the white king to
try and work out how to break through at
least wow it's uh
heating up well it's been hot for a
while actually in the quarterfinals in
uh the last one going on between ding
and artemyev
the bar has gone up four vladislav
artemyev who made a comeback winning
game three
he could be about to turn that
completely around and take the win in
like what final and get ready for
semifinals if it is a draw that game
then those two will play uh tie breaks
wow i mean there's so much kind of
symmetry going on in all these games
today there's patterns behind every game
that other game i just took a peek at me
up against ding
until this last move it was very similar
it was two bishops against two knights
also with white being upon up uh
actually right now artemis is two pawns
up as white but still not over just like
this game white's king in that one is
very weak so yes tell you if it looks
like he's doing well according to the
computer but ding still has many chances
left yeah i think we heard magnus um
saying about who he'd prefer to play and
i think it's clearly going to be artemia
because he's got a really big score
against him and ding he hasn't got such
a great score against you know ding is
one of those players who
attacks him and really goes for it so i
expect magnus is kind of hoping i'll
tell me if he's going to win that game
for his own benefit really if they've
played a few matches before and i know
that magnus won
i think the usms rapid pretty easily
against altamiaf yeah and but then i'm
like thinking about the tour finals and
i think
i'll tell you might have won that one
but don't right he did he did okay yeah
i think he won 3-1 against magnus it was
quite dominant in the tour finals but
magnus had already secured the tour
victory so yeah
maybe taking his eye off the ball
slightly meanwhile what we showed has
occurred on the board so white's queen
did take the black bishop and now black
has captured in the center it's back to
level material we're up for a really
exciting finish here i mean especially
as the time now is getting down to under
three minutes well for uh for especially
um as pienko but white's tanking time as
well now
um
eric doesn't look happy he's just been
he's rocking back and forth hands in his
head a bit
i think he's he knows that the control
has gone from the position but maybe he
doesn't realize how good his position is
that he still has chances i mean i'm
still trying to work out exactly what
white should be doing but just by
process of elimination there's nothing
else you have to move your knight and
you have to bring it forward to attack
that uh black bishop because other ways
this allowed that bishop out and this is
one mistake he's been making i think
eric he's been thinking a little bit too
much at the wrong time you've brought
this up before that if there's only one
kind of move you can play you can't
really take that pawn surely you have to
play it there's no point you know it's a
process of elimination here and i think
that that knight jumping is the only
move
you can play whether it's good or bad
you just have to play it it is the most
natural move right but uh maybe eric has
been swayed by just capturing the pawn
and thinking that he can consolidate in
a must-win situation he can't take that
pawn because then he's the one fighting
for the draw he's playing okay he's
played it okay he plays the most
ambitious move and probably the best
move as well he was attacking the black
bishop and the black queen now has swung
herself across
and
now defending her bishop but also
attacking the white knight
wow this is really really tense i'm
surprised by that as well though because
you can get rid of that bishop now and
create maybe just a a nice pass pawn uh
minimum push that pawn he's pushed it
happened look at that pawn that pawn is
three squares away from queening but
very secure the white king now looks
okay because there's no pieces that can
attack it hang on a minute eric yeah
this looks good yeah yeah good chances
and uh that's why estepanka actually
attacks the queen he doesn't allow white
to reinforce that white past white pawn
um
okay white's queen could centralize
itself you can maybe make an argument
for trading the rooks off first and then
moving the white queen but either way
another theme of the day isolated
queen's pawns max pawn in the center of
the world isolated and it's a huge
target for later so the queen does
centralize itself
okay and white's rook in the corner
looks like it's on a nice file but when
it does centralize
i mean black is the one fighting for the
draw now right white has no more risk
yeah eric does need to win however yeah
hey
chances of winning what do you think how
would you estimate them
difficult actually
and the reason i say this is because of
white's king
because white's king is just a little
bit open and yes the pieces are active
yes he has a past born but the white's
king if he always has to keep an eye on
that it's going to be
trouble don't don't think here though
why think you can't take with a pawn
your king becomes weaker don't lose a
brook take the rook with your queen and
don't waste 30 seconds on this move just
play it i mean it's like you
these seconds later on might come back
and haunt him
you really can't take with a pawn here
can you i mean
it doesn't make sense does it because uh
you would isolate your own porn weaken
your king exactly and you would and you
wouldn't challenge for the only open
line on the position i i'd be very
surprised if you
you know if you're going to take the
point you've got to go over your
instinct and eric's got that all these
players got great instincts and when
you're getting shorter time you have to
rely on that more and more
and
i think this this thinking here
is just not the right way to go and he's
taken with a queen but he he spent over
30 seconds of that move spent a minute
on that movie i think
it's exactly what jonathan rosen said in
the seven deadly chess since
perfectionism
you don't need to play perfect moves
when you've got two minutes on the clock
you need to play moves that are good
enough that are safe yeah and uh okay he
did play the most obvious move and
isopenko doing something that everyone
needs to do immediately the black
kingston breathing playing it
immediately as well and of course that
seven deadly sins is now a chesapeal
course
which you can get the very famous book
there and uh i think anyone who's read
it would recommend you you uh you get
the course and buy the book because it's
it's a really good book and it seems to
be your favorite among many top players
it's really well written and actually a
joy to read as well so uh okay the root
comes in the middle and uh still still
chances for eric though yeah serious
chances uh he would love this same
position but with that one minute extra
on his clock still uh now however i
expect esopenko to bring the black queen
maybe blockade that strong
protected well not quite protected by
that strong white past pawn
uh black's rook can't really get
anywhere too attractive right now
maybe you could make an argument for the
okay he does block that pawn the black
rook could have swung across white's
queen centralizes attacking black's pawn
on the b-file and
black counter-attacks against white's
past pawn
okay so eric defending he lost a bit of
time there he brought his rook across
then had to bring it back yeah it feels
like it feels like there's a bit of a
standoff going on and uh
white is just forced to defend his past
pawn black just attacks it what next
he's gone passive hasn't yeah white
can't really move get active now that
last rook move is not not something you
want to do and uh i can't see how he can
make progress here maybe he has to just
throw the pawns even further now
well i don't really believe it you know
so
but you might as well lose yeah it
doesn't matter you know so uh exactly
yeah i like your idea simon advance all
the pawns come forward with the king
maybe clear the h line
harry i'm not believing it but uh i yeah
okay i mean
after this nice last move by black
bringing the rook across to an open file
it feels like
eric
will things turn against him unless he's
accurate here maybe white rook needs to
just side step now attack black's pawn
in the middle of the board
otherwise black might be the one taking
control yeah
but i suppose then black's root can come
back and uh um
espnko's king is so safe as we've
mentioned it doesn't both sides have one
pawn weakness
looking looking like sapno's got control
now um eric under a minute all of a
sudden as well and he has gone for this
is the rook just going to come back now
keep the pressure up go for the ending
yeah most likely blacksmith can return
to back back where it came from
attacking white passport
i don't think you really want to go
passive i was going to say and then he
does it he does it
but i mean then in that case
that whole rook
maneuver that essie panko has just done
it doesn't really make so much sense
before there was like a complete
standoff now there's maybe some chance
for eric to start
pushing and you can see now his rook has
gotten active and i suddenly i really
like
eric's position the problem is what next
it's still a standoff uh i don't really
see no matter where the white rook goes
the black rook will basically just copy
yeah and white queen is stuck black's
queen stuck this is here he comes i
think you have to try this i mean i
don't believe it because your own king
is going to come weaker but what else
can you try you can't really do anything
you're queen and rook you're you're
running out of options just try to
create some possibilities over here well
now if he does the same thing he gains
the tempo it's quite strange so if he
goes back
[Music]
just sensing that one change in the
position now he's going for the white
king with the black rook he's trying to
swing it across very very impressive
play from sapienka i think just being
patient taking his opportunity when he
can and also moving quicker now so yeah
not easy to play look at eric's clock 30
seconds and white's king is the weaker
of the two okay wow
and it looks like we're not gonna have
tie breaks today you guys if uh this one
is a draw uh then or a win for ezeko
then uh he's gonna be in the semi-finals
and the bar all the way over to our
tamiya side in that game
wow
i just took a peek over i'll tell you if
he's a porn up with better pieces as
well in his game so he's a big favorite
to knock out ding
and that would be a massive turnaround
in the match he was moves away from
getting knocked out himself
yeah that's how much chess can change
right we talked about it one move in in
the last game and uh suddenly ding went
from almost through to the semis to
being out so do you do you think uh in
this position
that uh estepanka will rock the boat and
try to
do something different or okay as we've
seen he's just gonna follow the formula
i i think he's saying to eric it's like
it's over to you no i don't have to do
anything you have to do something i
think whatever you do will make your
position worse and uh he he's just going
to wait which he's doing at the moment
uh eric pushing that pawn
not sure how he's going to open it up
now after pushing the 8.1 square
forwards
um
both getting under a minute yeah there's
an idea that you can maybe lift up your
rook to the third row well okay no i was
and then why not do it still you thank
you yes okay yeah and then try to take
control of the uh
of the e open e line
swinging all the rooks today in every
position right yeah middle game end game
opening i love that idea actually yeah
if you can get the rook over you might
even better get it behind your g-pawn
push that pawn that's something and he's
done it he's played it so there's still
it's there's still life there's still
chances for their eric hanson fans out
there every position with queens or
rooks on there's always life no matter
how
kind of simple it looks and here we go
esopenko lacking a plan just yo-yoing
back and forth with the black queen
white's rook does have a move to try and
swing across and do something it's not
clear entirely
uh what he should be doing with that
rook because as soon as the white rogue
moves blackstrike will slide to the c
file okay using uh can you go look in
front of the king but you know just
trying to go trying to push the g pawn i
mean just go for it i was thinking go
for complete domination put the rook on
the open e-line because you can use
tactics
to hold on to your pawn okay he goes
back where he came from i like that idea
anchor yeah i also like your simon i
mean there are definitely plans for
white but they all involved involved
having the white rook on the third rank
and he's just gone back
he wants to repeat once
surely just to gain 10 seconds on the
clock and then try something different i
had to move 10 seconds i see your idea
vancouver you wanted to go with some
check and yeah i like it i like it
because you know harry has gone really
far up the board and the black king not
safe okay if we have if we have time
we'll show that later but right now it's
really tense under 20 seconds for hanson
yeah and he's not really making progress
i think he's gone the wrong way with the
white rook
ten second must-win situation for eric
hanson he had a great tournament so far
can you turn this one around
he's just repeating the position not
making any progress right now he's just
i think he's got one eye on the clock
he's just trying to gain 10 seconds
every turn but you can't play safe chess
when you need a win
and you've got to be very careful you
don't fall into your perpetual so he has
to play a move like this he has to try
to uh
make sure that he doesn't repeat the
position and just put his king on a dim
square i think this is so risky every
time you take a step up the board with
your king the king gets a bit shaky take
the open file surely now take it now yes
you've got to go for it and look at that
ladies love artemiev has
turned that
quart final around and is ready for the
semi-final to face magnus carlsen
wow i guess that shows us what momentum
shift can do in chess but we have to
follow this game until the end
can eric hansen get that win that he
needs
he's
trying he's trying everything but he's
not stumbling across the right plan he's
just moving his rook back and forth he's
worried about the clock
but that's not going to help him that's
not going to get him through uh we'll
fight back in this match white's queen
now abandoning the central outpost maybe
this is clever maybe white's queen's
going to try and jump in and trade
herself off for the black queen yeah
okay i like the idea because at least
okay black stuff says no but now maybe
you just push the g pawn and really
gamble you know um well i don't know but
you have to gamble at some point
you have to he's really in danger of
repeating the position three times
white's king is on a different square
than it was earlier but if you ever
retreat it it might just be a three-fold
repetition and a draw so he's got to be
really careful here he's kind of i mean
maybe he's trying to gain time he's
confusing himself
lift that rook up onto the third rank
that's the only possible plan now i
agree
15 seconds the clock is ticking is eric
keeping a calm head he's pushing all of
his pawns forward there's no way back
it's do or die time i i've been at least
this is the right way to play i mean if
you don't see the rook lift you have to
move your pawns forwards you have to try
to open up the black king he's he's got
an idea now the idea is to just keep
pushing those guys and just trying to go
go for the black king with the pawns
so safe
white's king
we have the saying like uh well david
has a saying with great space comes
great responsibility
i like it yeah look how many squares
white has to cover now to avoid the
white king getting checked
yeah it's good danger zone now do you
know what it is i mean it's that minute
think he had because if he had an extra
minute in this position
he might have he might have found that
rug swing okay but he's still trying
queen exchange keeps the game alive
and no queen trade because that would
have helped white white's king is closer
to the center and meanwhile black just
continuing to repeat the position you
know
everything that eric tries look at him
yeah he's trying it out you actually saw
scs banker actually breathe a sight of
relief on the cameras meanwhile
eric is just
head in his hands in frustration he
can't make it work right everything he
tries he's just getting there in his
face he has to make a move oh he's gone
for it again but the queen comes back
what's he going to do he has to try
something different five just push the
pawn and pray
push and pray
[Laughter]
well he has to take the decision quickly
okay he's done another prayer move
he hit the black rook but the black rook
oh no is that a blunder wow right now
white has lost control black central
pawn could just push forward black can
just swing the rook across
this one i would just push the central
pawn forward as black now
white's queen is not doing great and
it's left the blockade this is a past
pawn it's running down the board
white's king is going to be under fire
as well what about going queen d6 queen
queen but the queen can snake her way
one last little trick you take the queen
off i might queen my paw one second eric
had when he made that last move
one second left but now black can
continue pushing this pawn black can
even bring the queen to the center
oh look at this oh black could bring the
queen right down into the corner maybe
that's just deadly bring okay
this one is strong as well this is good
yeah and uh probably yes
going to find it in the next move
because i think yes there's also a rook
check once the white queen moves out the
way black's rook is going to come down
with a check that's going to be
checkmate white's king to open
well he had to do this i mean uh he
could have held the draw but he had to
he had to gamble so i mean
his king was actually too weak there in
the end but
why not go down and blaze the glory
rather than fade away and that's what
he's done he's gone down and he blazed
the glory or oh well
you know only an option essepenko
relieved he knows he's got this in the
back no matter where the white king goes
there will be a check and there will be
a checkmate on the next three or four
moves it's over